hi i'm christopher hine and talk to you
guys today about 20 years of live
training in aikido specifically my 20
years of live training in aikido
when i started looking for live training
my aikido i didn't even know the word
for it i didn't know there was a word
live training it wasn't until years
later that i was doing live training in
brazilian jiu jitsu that i discovered
there was a word for this stuff
what i used to just say was i need to
see it really happening and the reason
that i needed to see it really happening
was because i had been
an aikido student um at a big aikido
school uh i was uchidashi a living
student meaning i was studying all the
time i lived there i was teaching all
the kids classes and doing stuff
constantly constantly constantly
and
after i got my showdown which is first
degree black belt i happened to get into
a fight and after the fight was over i
was like hey i didn't do any aikido
that's really strange because for the
last three or so years of my life i've
been living eating and breathing aikido
i'm a black belt in aikido you would
think that i would have done some aikido
in that fight but
no kodagaisha's no ikyos no nikkyos no
nothing came out in that fight and i
didn't know
why
so my original theory was
when i was growing up as a kid i had
gotten a lot of fights and i knew what
that kind of fighting was and in aikido
school i had just done forms so i didn't
do any fighting and so when i got into a
fight my thought was oh i just clicked
back into my old ways and i needed to
learn how to bridge the gap between my
old ways and my aikido what i did was i
went to a lot of the local schools here
i went to the local boxing gym i went to
the karate school i went to there's a
small brazilian jiu jitsu school here at
the time
and i just tried my stuff with those
guys and
again i really didn't have much success
i also realized that that
way of looking at it wasn't going to
work because it's really kind of weird
to show up at a school and be like hey i
want to spar with your guys a little bit
strange strange thing to do so i was
like i need a school where they're
regularly
again i would say this now live training
um but at the time i was just like
sparring and stuff and then i'll just
keep practicing my aikido stuff until i
can do it with these guys that i'm
sparring with
so i found a small school in southern
california run by tim carmel tim
carmel's a traditional martial artist
who came uh who lived in china and
studied traditional forms of kung fu and
and fought in tournaments there in china
and then came back to the united states
and studied brazilian jiu-jitsu with
clever luciano and uh was at that time
of brown bell he's gone on to be a black
belt in brazilian jiu jitsu um and he's
really into mixed martial arts and
grappling and how all that works and so
this school seemed like a good school
for me a traditional guy who was trying
to bridge that into
applicable skill so i moved to southern
california i started studying with tim
cartmell full time i was staying there
all the time
and i was entering brazilian jiu jitsu
tournaments and submission wrestling
tournaments and mixed martial arts so i
was competing in different stuff and
through all my sparring and the
tournaments i went in i never saw any
aikido stuff up here so i really started
to feel like well that stuff just
doesn't work it's just it's just not
useful stuff um and this i kind of was
like well i'll probably i want to teach
martial arts so i'll probably teach
mixed martial arts or something because
aikido really doesn't work then a friend
of mine who competes in dog brothers
tournaments a maynard in chetah invited
me to go with him to a dog brothers
meeting of the pack so i went to a drug
brothers meeting in the pack and i
fought with a uh we would call it a joe
and aikido but um it was a bondo sticks
a long rattan stick and i had a fight
with one of the dog brothers and i did
pretty well and what surprised me the
most was aikido stuff appeared in fact
one of the guys who came with me uh
bumped one of the other guys in the
thing and said hey he's an aikido guy
and he laughed because he's like oh an
aikido guy wouldn't do that but it's
like it did it did aikido stuff worked
right so
i was really shocked by this so what i
did was i ended up quitting that school
and moving back and focusing just on
aikido because i wanted to see how
aikido worked that was my original
intent going there and i kind of given
up on it but when after i fought in this
dog brothers fight it was like hey look
this stuff works
so
what i did was i started all kinds of
different sparring iterations under my
own control so i didn't have to try to
do brazilian jiu jitsu or mixed martial
arts or whatever else and i could change
the way in which we were fighting and i
would now call that context so i could
change the context around in order to
understand what was happening and i
started to slowly discover things one of
the first discoveries i made and this is
kind of a no-brainer but i had to make
it on a first-hand basis was traditional
jiu-jitsu is closely related to aikido
and traditional jiu-jitsu has a
different context and emphasis than
modern jiu-jitsu right so traditional
jiu-jitsu was an armed grappling system
it was a grappling system where guys
were always had weapons on them so the
grappling wouldn't exist without pulling
out knives and different weapons so
jiu-jitsu traditional jiu-jitsu
accounted for weapon context and that
tag those techniques were really closely
related to aikido and so at first i
thought aikido was an armed grappling
system so jigoro kano had clarified uh
traditional jiu-jitsu and modified it
into a new system which was an unarmed
system and then the gracie family and
and people in brazil had taken it
further and made it into a more
specified ground grappling system but
aikido was kind of untouched and left
like traditional jiu-jitsu so the
context of that was
armed grappling
so my original ideas of how aikido must
work had to do with weapons and i was
like it's some kind of armed grappling
system and that's what i really thought
um and i was a real advocate of this you
know it's it's an arm grappling system
so the two video clips i'm putting in
here are from early attempts in 2007
these are both from january 2007 uh
the in the video is me and michael varen
sensei we were we co-owned that school
together and when everyone would leave
we'd lock the door and then we would
just get together and we would try this
stuff out right so this is armed
grappling attempts now at the time i
would have said oh this is what aikido
live training looks like and now i
realize that there's a whole lot more to
it than this but these are our first
attempts at that
okay so we were starting these off from
a grab so we weren't worrying at the
time about anything that was done
pre-grab so that's not the focus we were
trying to see aikido techniques and so
right here you can see a sankyo coming
off and turning into a yonkyo and so i'm
turning uchimori's what you call that
nikita setting up a sankyo trying to get
the sankyo turning that into a yonkyo
michael turned his back switched knife
hands and came after me you're gonna see
a lot of that switching because in the
beginning didn't really understand how
to stop knife switches
so all this clinch work you're seeing is
not indicative of classic aikido but at
the time i was completely ignoring that
and the idea was i wanted to see aikido
techniques come off and so when there's
an emphasis on these wrist grabs that
will happen so here's the second clip
again we're starting from the wrist grab
mike's trying to cut me whenever he can
and trying to get free so that's his
objective my objective is to get the
weapon from him or get him into a
controllable position so we're trying to
emulate what i think aikido is which is
at this time i think it's some kind of
uh jiu-jitsu remnant
so you can see there mike's cutting my
wrist uh played that a few times you can
see
these are things actually let me stop
this real quick these are the things
you'll see a lot in these videos because
these early videos because
we really didn't have a concept of how
to keep the person from cutting you
other than just holding the wrist hard
and as we
get better at it you'll see that
starting to happen less and less and
less
honestly i believe those things are
accounted for in the forums i just
didn't know how to interpret them at the
time so
you'll see a lot of that knife switching
and a lot of
cutting even though it's being held so
i'll go ahead and start her again here
so here you see a classic variation of
something that looks like a shionage
again this is a classic jiu-jitsu
technique so these techniques are coming
out effortlessly because that's the
situation here against the sankyo with a
classic sankyo udeo say takedown so i
played it several times so it's easy to
see
i'm going to stop the video here for
just a second so understand that
when you're not used to seeing igloo
techniques done in the wild right done
without a script they don't look the
same they're done faster they're done
more offhanded they're done without the
kind of form you would see in a formal
way to do it so these are michael trying
to stop me as hard as he can and me
trying to get the technique as far as i
can so
sometimes you need to see him over and
over so that's why i've kind of looped a
couple spots here so you can kind of see
the essence of that form there
and there again michael switched and
stabbed me so still didn't know how to
account for that
and here we're getting back into that
same position i'm trying the same setup
and i turned that into sayonage so
something you would see in judo and some
aikido styles
again we set back up with the grab
and a switch over and you see i tried to
isolate that hand couldn't this sets up
a myotosh for mic so mike sets up on my
toast right here classic aikido
technique again set up
and he cuts me at the end just just for
fun
i'm going into the clinch again
trying to keep him from switching trying
to hold him as tight as i can
michael does it clear there he tries
immediately for a sumiya posh doesn't
work i grab his back to stop him he
switches knife hands and stabs me
there was a nico in there he didn't see
it happen real fast he cut my arm and he
stabbed me
and at that point i think i was saying
you know like oh this is real hard it's
real hard for you to or for me to stop
that so um these are the early attempts
i don't know how long we had been
doing this on our own this i don't think
these are the first two times we did it
but they're the first recordings i could
find of us doing it um
but this is the ideas we were trying to
make it like uh japanese jiu jitsu or
trying to discover what those ideas were
of this armed grappling system is that's
what i thought it was i thought it was
an arm grappling system at the time now
there's lots of things that you'll see
in this that you don't see in classic
aikido there's lots of clinch work
you don't see that in classic aikido and
so that was one of the burning questions
i had for a long time which is like why
don't you see this clinch work if it's
so important because here you can see
it's clearly important to us so
that's it for these two videos these two
are are kind of isolated i'm going to
show the progression out of this so as
we started to progress out of this
and then this this whole year of 2007
for us was a big adaptation i think by
the time we got to the end of this year
we really were starting to hone in on
what
aikido was what its context was and how
it worked
and in a live way so i hope you enjoyed
these videos uh there will be more
coming uh so i'm still going through old
footage and trying to put it together in
a sensible way so you guys can tell and
kind of figure out how to explain the
steps we're making so hope you enjoyed
this video and we'll see you again soon
i'm christopher hine thanks a lot for
watching
[Music]